ja viele sind sauer weil flüge
gestrichen werden und sie nicht in den
urlaub kommen aber manchmal ist das
sogar besser
unglaublich diese szenen spielten sich
in diesem fünf sterne hotel in der
türkei ab das beach und spare tor la fat
bei antalya die anlage präsentiert sich
im internet als schickes nobel hotel
oder besser gesagt ekel hotel bild-leser
nsd wedges aus pforzheim fünfte für sich
und seine frau eine woche für
1377 euro aber der vermeintliche
traumurlaub entpuppte sich als albtraum
der filialleiter schickte einen hilferuf
an die bild-redaktion
baden im essen schimmel in der dusche
und prügeln des hotelpersonals diese
bilder verschlagen einem die sprache und
verderben einen den appetit je eine
schlägerei hier sein magen darm virus
man kann hier nichts essen es ist
dreckig und
jetzt sind sich hier noch leute
anklopfen umschlagen kinder sind
involviert das ist das hotelpersonal was
ich geklaut
mit gesten dreck insekten im müsli und
das hotelpersonal prügelt auf gäste ein
weil die sich über die unzumutbaren
zustände beschweren
und deswegen ist das problem entstanden
meint die zeichen und dann hat jetzt
wirklich leiden unglaubliche bilder und
heftige vorwürfe bild fragte beim
reiseportal check24 nach das portal für
dem paar das geld voll erstatten und
entschuldigt sich in aller form für die
unannehmlichkeiten inzwischen ist es der
wird mit seiner frau in ein anderes
hotel umgezogen ganz klar so möchte man
nicht urlaub machen um keinen preis denn
die schönen werbebilder des hotels haben
mit der realität überhaupt nichts zu tun
hier sollten sie auf gar keinen fall
einchecken
[Musik]